j'accueille aujourd'hui air interfel
journaliste au quotidien anglophone
vegas elle est éditée rarement landes et
le fun et journaliste spécialisé en
santé bonjour et le bonjour
alors revenons de fun vous avez écrit la
dernière année beaucoup sur la copie de
19 ce qui vous a valu une nomination aux
concours canadien du journaliste 2020
dans la catégorie journalisme spécialisé
alors je vais vous poser la question
classique qu'est ce que ça représente
pour vous cette nomination je suis un
très ferme à 1 pour ce prix mais d'abord
fier et aussi je suis content d'être en
compagnie avec d'autres jeunes qui sont
rénovés comme ariane lacoursière de la
presse donc vous avez fait que j'étais
nommé 30 finalistes c'est déjà quelque
chose si je gagne par elodie vous êtes
vous êtes spécialisé en santé
comment vous êtes devenu spécialisé en
santé oms le journalisme ça fait 22 ans
s'était ensuite du décidément d'heure
ils étaient atteints de cancer et j'ai
discuté jeu
à l'époque j'étais très impliqué dans
son soin et je voulais vraiment peur
j'ai décidé d'écrire sur la santé et on
a constaté qu'il y avait beaucoup de
problèmes dans les réseaux un manille à
22 ans
l'état d'urgence était engorgé
même en il ya vingt deux ans dans ces
moments difficiles nouveau défi avance
en gt la culture de l'hôtel de ville
et c'était pour moi un peu ennuyant à la
fin donc mais pas avec la santé il ya la
recherche qui avance toujours
il y a un
le problème structurel de notre système
1 aussi il ya des défis au niveau des
tic
lorsqu'on parle des technologies de la
reproduction et donc c'est pour moi
c'est toujours fascinant
j'apprends des choses quotidiennement
et puis quand la pandémie nous a frappés
c'était un défi pour tout le monde
depuis un an et c'était pour moi aussi
une devoir défendre les gens donc c'est
quelque chose qui est toujours fascinant
pour la santé je comprends donc vous
vous intéressez à la santé comme objet
de recherche sur le même ton camp comme
services aux citoyens comment est ce
qu'il est que - est-ce qu'il est fourni
or vous l'année dernière quand au québec
étaient tous au début de la pandémie au
québec tout semblait être sous contrôle
puisqu'ils avaient chaque jour y
conférence de presse les gens suivaient
les consignes et puis un jour elle
interfère le sort son article sur la
résidence pour personnes âgées et pour
les soins de longue durée et rome
hélas tout a changé qu'est ce qui s'est
passé ce jour c'était à cette date là
c'était le chaos total à l'arc de danse
il y avait une éclosion de la croix
ville 19 à mais en même temps il y avait
des des effectifs d'être posée aux
bénéficiaires et des infirmières qui
sont tombés malades mais à autre un
travailleurs et travailleuses qui ont
décidé d'abandonner un la résidence
parce qu'ils avaient peur d'attraper la
cabine 19 d'onglets et puis les aînés
étaient un négligé
et puis à un moment donné un
je pense qu'il ya le soir il restait
soit un ou deux travailleuses dans une
des déficits et 130 personnes ainsi que
je pense d'eux
le matin le vent nos semences 2020 et
puis les autorités ont découvert qu' il
y avait un banc dans un coin ils sont
arrivés ils ont découvert que les
résidents et étudiants triés
il était temps de crise mans leur caca
il y avait même un des membres constaté
les corps dans les lits 1
donc c'était une scène un tragique et je
pense est aussi choquant parce qu'on n'a
jamais pensé que pensé que quelque chose
comme ça pourrait arriver au québec mais
mais comment comment s'est passée sous
le radar
les comment vous vous l'avez découvert
et les autorités ne l'avaient pas ne
l'avait pas vu mais je pense que c'est
peut-être le système un problème
structurel
on a des de l'enseirb dallaire qui ou
des gens qui travaillent dans le système
digestif qui veut pas des fois parlé des
problèmes pour toutes sortes de raisons
et puis un jd sauce une sauce qui m'a
appelé pour me décrire la situation
donc je pense que c'était que ça le fait
que les journalistes et les lanceurs
d'alors la confiance envers des gens s
qui pourrait écrire ce sursaut leur
histoire et c'est ce qui est arrivé dans
mon cas avec l'histoire de deux jeunes
et puis et cette histoire vous a valu un
peu des problèmes de relations avec le
premier ministre du québec
ils vous emmènent bloqué sur twitter qu
est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce que
vous avez fait de pas bien pour que ou
qui là qu'il a un peu énervé qu'est ce
qui s'est passé mais aurait rejeté
il a réagi il a réagi rapidement les
lendemains qui l'agaçait tu as tout dit
la fille qui est renfermé mais
effectivement il y avait 1 1 vingt sept
27 sept
que j'ai écrit dans mon texte mais
plutôt à 31 décès et il a annoncé qu'il
engagerait d'être apte ou de proposer
aux bénéficiaires pour traiter un peu
donner les soins en reste dans et pour
inspecter aussi des séances et des rives
et non conventionnés il a ordonné une
enquête sociale
alors je pense que c'est ça n'a rien à
voir
ça ne veut rien à voir avec un run avec
lui c'est plutôt les enfilades que
j'écris sur twitter quand j'ai fait
vérifier ces affirmations quand il a il
a fait une comparaison avec l'allemagne
pour tenter de démontrer qu'il y avait
tout le québec était la situation au
québec était pas aussi mauvais les gens
pensaient et à la cij et vérifier ces
affirmations j'ai vérifié les faits je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui les
aimait pas peut-être et je me souviens
aussi à un moment donné il a avancé la
date pour l'arrivée des écoles à
montréal à l'extérieur on met en avril a
annoncé quelques semaines avant que les
écoles rouvrent verrez et puis hein mais
en même temps il y avait une
augmentation des décès toujours une
augmentation du décès et des cas et des
hospitalisations dont un réseau et puis
je me demander pourquoi il était
tellement motivés pour y ouvrir un les
écoles lorsqu'il lorsqu'il pandémie
était et est toujours difficile au
québec et il n'a pas un
il n'a pas cité un critère une bonne
critères
les critères établis par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé ou de la maison
blanche
il fallait attendre pendant je pense à
l'époque il fallait attendre depuis 14
jours une diminution constante des des
hospitalisations et des cas pour faire
une espèce de relâchement apport et
ouvrir la société 1 1 dont c'était
quelque chose qui j'ai trouvé bizarre
parce que j'ai eu gg je l'avais fait des
comparaisons c'est ça exactement je
pense qu'ils n'étaient pas à l'aise avec
cette critique un ami ce que j'ai fait
c'était mon devoir comme jean mdd se
desserrer que nos élus nos leaders
politiques soit un tuteur et et pour
vérifier les faits et les affirmations
de nos leaders politiques nos devoirs 30
juin c'est notre responsabilité d'un
étang contexte de situation
vous n'êtes pas obligé de croire sur
parole vous vérifié c'est ça le rôle du
journal et sinon vous sinon il ya les
porte paroles il ya les chargés de
communication et dites moi ok l'année
dernière il y avait cette zone d'ombré
est ce que cette année est ce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui est qui passe sous le
radar du gouvernement ici au québec
selon votre analyse à vous par exemple
en ce moment où il y à une troisième
vague même temps il ya comme une
ouverture commun mais les confinements
autant est-ce que vous emportez à la
suite rien c'était un point tournant
je pense que à la suite les gens et
c'était beaucoup plus agressif et je
pense que le jeu au québec est tout à
fait exceptionnel je parle de radio
qu'un dans la presse le devoir de gens à
montréal beaucoup de jeu et même des
hôpitaux
magar qui font de travail exceptionnel
et je pense que maintenant il n'ya pas
vraiment des choses qui passent au vert
et d'art
et met en phase avec avec la troisième
vague les variants 1
mais je pense qu'il ya est ce qu ont
raté des choses peut-être dead
non je pense que non parce que parce que
le premier ministre et le gouvernement
est vraiment sur le dos des gens est
beaucoup plus que ans elle a emprunté le
printemps dernier
merci et wonderful je rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste au quotidien anglophone
the gazette édité à montréal merci
d'avoir accepté l'invitation
ça me fait plaisir à voir